you lost a lot of weight and you been
very open about it and it's been a big
part of your comedy as well as I know
and one of the thing that surprised me
as I was talking about it and you told
me that your friends have not been that
helpful no that's kind of weird I
thought your friends would really sort
of try and hold you up during this time
and cheer you want you said that's not
the case I mean they were at a beginning
you know when I wasn't a threat to them
having sex with people but now you know
if they're afraid if they see a lady
sees them standing next to me they got
no shot no we're just drew most of my
friends are not doing better than me in
any fashion right seems to be weighing
on you heavily but they don't support me
I try to take my best friend Gabe on the
road with me and I'm pretty much keeping
him alive so I'm like the least you
could do is work out with me on the road
and he's like oh I fell asleep because I
ate too many nacho fries it's not hope
not no-one's hoping you know
well my girlfriend's very helpful yeah
yeah that's nice yeah but I don't like
it